[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEREMY WALKER: Hi.
My name's Jeremy Walker.
Welcome to YouTube
Developers Live.
Today is all about WordPress.
We're actually to talk about a
plug-in that we've kind of
released under the radar called
the YouTube Upload
Widget plug-in.
And today, actually, I
have Pete Mall with
me today from Range.
Say hi, Pete.
PETE MALL: Hi.
JEREMY WALKER: So Pete actually
wrote the code for
the plug-in itself to take
advantage of the widget.
And I think that's all
in PHP, right?
PETE MALL: Yeah, all PHP.
JEREMY WALKER: Yeah.
So what we're going to actually
do is Pete's going to
talk a little bit about
WordPress in case any of you
don't know about it who
live under a rock.
And he's going to talk a
little bit about Range.
And then I'm going to give a
little bit of history of what
our new plug-in does and
how we came about it.
And we're going to go into a
demo, and then some code.
So why don't we get started.
Why don't you tell us
about WordPress.
PETE MALL: So for this of you
who don't know WordPress, it's
a content management system.
It started about 10 years ago
as a blogging system, a
blogging platform.
And I guess over the
years, it's not
just for blogs anymore.
We can see full-blown sites as
well as even apps that are
being powered by WordPress
on the back end now.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So what is Range?
And how does that come into
play with WordPress?
PETE MALL: So Range is a
full-service design and
development agency that I
started last year with a
couple of other WordPress
core contributors.
And we've just been doing
WordPress work for the last
year, including plug-ins and
custom sites for people.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
So for any of you that don't
know, we obviously have the
YouTube APIs that let
you do a lot of the
things you do on YouTube.
Via APIs, maybe even in your
apps, one of those things is
uploading video.
And what we did a little while
ago is, we decided we wanted
to make uploading video
much easier.
So we made the YouTube Upload
Widget, which not only allows
you to choose a file to upload
to YouTube, but it also allows
you to record a video from
your webcam and upload
directly to YouTube.
So we wanted to take advantage
of that widget and expose it
to the WordPress folks so that
they can use it within their
environment without having to go
and mess around in YouTube.
So that's where we came into
contact with you, through some
of the WordPress folks.
And you guys took it from there
and built out a nice
little plug-in using
this widget.
And why don't we just
dive into and have
a look at it live?
PETE MALL: Yeah.
So, real quick, the plugin
lives on WordPress.org.
If you go there, look
under Plug-ins.
You'll be able to search for
the YouTube Upload Widget.
And for those of you who are not
familiar with WordPress,
this is how the dashboard
looks like.
So the first thing I'm going to
do is go ahead and install
the plug-in.
And I'm searching
for the plug-in.
And it should be
the first one.
And looks like it's already
installed for me.
So I'm just going to go ahead
and create a new post so I can
test out the functionality.
So WordPress, by default, ships
with this media manager
that lets you insert images,
galleries, either from your
computer or from another
source on the web.
And we just wanted to flow the
same UI and make it that easy
for you to use your YouTube
videos or just record a video
from inside WordPress without
ever having to log into
another site.
So we have this YouTube
button here.
If you click that, it opens
a similar pop-up.
And the first thing it's going
to ask you is a title for the
new video that you're
trying to record.
I'm just going to
say Test Video.
And you can have a description
there which
flows through to YouTube.
And you can have keywords that
are going to be attached to
your video.
JEREMY WALKER: I noticed you
guys are installing the
reference to the blog, which
is really helpful.
So if someone finds your video
on YouTube, they can click on
this, and it'll take them to
the post related to that.
So it drives traffic
both ways.
PETE MALL: And you can always
edit this description.
You can add more to it and still
leave the link in there,
so it's easy to go back and
forth between your blog and
your YouTube account.
So I'm just going to go
ahead and click on
the Record from Webcam.
And that pops up the YouTube
Upload Widget
that you guys created.
And it tells me I'm
logged in as Pete
Mall, which is my account.
And it gives me a button to
record for my webcam.
JEREMY WALKER: Now, if he hadn't
logged in already, he
would have gotten an
authorization window coming up
to authorize.
PETE MALL: Yeah.
It's the same OAuth window
that pops up.
You log in.
You give it permissions
to the YouTube account
to upload the video.
So I can see myself.
And I can just click
Start Recording.
And it's going to say, do you
really want to give access to
your webcam to YouTube?
I say yes.
And I can record anything.
It doesn't matter whether
it's five seconds
or it's five minutes.
It will just go through.
It's the power of YouTube
behind the scenes.
I clicked Stop Recording.
So now I can either go back and
look through my video and
see if I like it.
If I need to re-record
it, I can.
But if I'm happy with it,
I can just click Upload.
And if you look, it's already
got the ID for the video.
So I can just directly
insert the video into
the post right now.
Or I can wait a few seconds
until the video is done
processing.
And then I'll actually see the
processed video show up here
and still insert the link.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And so I guess while that's
uploading, so there's another
way to handle this as well--
oh, there we go.
I'll let you insert it.
PETE MALL: So again, the
video's now live.
I can insert it into my post.
And this uses oEmbed support,
which is baked into WordPress.
So even if you're not using
this, if you want to directly
copy a link to a YouTube video
and post it, as soon as you
publish, it will use oEmbed to
actually grab that video.
And if I just click on View Post
now, I see my new post
with the video that I just
recorded in there.
And so I don't need to fumble
with any embed codes or
anything else.
I just use the link directly.
JEREMY WALKER: That's great.
So--
and I was actually asking about
this just a second ago.
So let's say you want to insert
video from YouTube, but
you don't necessarily want to
upload or record anything.
Maybe you have something in
mind that'll help add some
more color to your post.
PETE MALL: Yeah.
So there's a lot of times
when you just
want to record something.
But there's times when you
already have something
recorded, or you found a really
cool video that you
want to embed.
Or if you're just writing a post
and you want to search
for something, you can go to
the second tab, which is
Browse YouTube Videos.
And it gives you a
field to search.
So I could just say WordPress.
And if I click Find Videos,
it'll use the
Feeds API from YouTube.
And it grabs the videos that
match my search terms.
And same way, I could go through
and preview the video,
or I can just click Insert.
Oh, there's the video
from Matt Cutts
about SEO and WordPress.
So we'll insert that one
into the post as well.
So again, I can have
multiple videos.
Or I could just move
my other video.
As soon as I click Update,
this goes ahead
and updates my post.
So I have both my videos, and
it's right there for you.
JEREMY WALKER: So one thing we
always like at Google is
open-source, and the code
for the plug-in is all
open-source.
So anyone that's interested
in grabbing the code and
extending it can certainly
do that.
If you want to show a little
bit about that
and talk about it?
PETE MALL: So you touched
upon open-source.
WordPress itself is released
under a GPL license, which
means it's free.
So you can download it and do
anything you want with it as
long as you maintain the
GPL restrictions
that come with it.
Also, any plug-in or theme
that's built on WordPress has
to either be released under
a GPL license or a license
that's compatible under
the GPL license.
So it gives you the same
freedoms as the creators have.
Again, if you go to
WordPress.org and search for
the plug-ins, you can search for
the YouTube Upload Widget.
And it will get you
to this page.
It has the info on
your licensing.
It has the features,
installation instructions,
some screenshots, as
well as support.
So if you have any issues, you
can just click Support, and
you can add a post to
it, and someone will
either get back to you.
Or there's a huge community in
WordPress where someone would
be able to help you.
The code itself lives on SVN
under WordPress.org.
So if you click on the
Developers tab, you'll have
access to the development log,
the SVN repository, as well as
a browse track, which is one of
the bug tracking systems we
use with WordPress.
But if I just want to look at
the SVN, I could see that all
of the code base lives there.
JEREMY WALKER: Great.
And so it's pretty basic,
the code you wrote.
You just separated it into
the pop-up window.
And it's PHP, so there's just
a couple files that they can
browse through, correct?
PETE MALL: Yes.
So real quick, I've broken the
code up into YouTube.php,
which, if you look through it,
it has the WordPress-specific
bootstrap at the top.
It tells us is the plug-in name
and a little bit about
the license and everything
else.
And this is the file that we use
to hook into WordPress, to
add the button, and tell
WordPress to open a pop-up
window when someone
clicks on it.
And the second file
is yt-popup.php.
This is the file that actually
powers the pop-up.
It embeds the YouTube Upload
Widget, and it's the one that
grabs the search API to show
that as the videos for you.
So again, most of the code is
HTML, with some sprinkling of
PHP in here.
And it just uses the
JavaScript API.
So everyone's more than happy
to browse through the code.
If there's any enhancements you
guys like, we're more than
happy to send in a request,
and we'll look
through your patch.
JEREMY WALKER: Awesome.
Well, thanks again for showing
this to us and the great work
you did on it.
We really appreciate it.
If you're interested,
check it out.
If you do use WordPress, you
should definitely install the
plug-in and start
playing with it.
It will definitely make
things a little bit
more easy for you.
And we don't have any
questions today.
But if any of you are interested
in a job it with
YouTube or with YouTube
Developer Advocates, please go
to our site--
developers.google.com/jobs--
and check it out.
We're always looking to
hire great developers.
And I think that covers
it for the show.
Thanks again for coming today.
We really appreciate it.
And yeah, again, check out
the WordPress blog.
Thanks, guys.
PETE MALL: CHEERS.
[MUSIC PLAYING]